.
Sind wir schon beim Check-in?
- Noch nicht ganz, aber auf dem Weg.
(Audiodeskription) Eine Mitarbeiterin
führt zwei junge Männer zum Check-in.
Beide haben
einen weissen Stock bei sich.
Du hast auch einen weissen Stock?
Ich dachte, der sei vielleicht blau.
Im Flugzeug.
Von mir aus müssen wir sie
heute nicht brauchen.
Einer der Männer
zieht eine Rettungsweste über.
"Einer der Männer",
waren wir da schon Mann genug?
Schon der erste schlechte Witz
von Yves.- Ja.
Blick aus dem Fenster:
Das Flugzeug fliegt über weisse,
watteartige Wolken,
später über eine Stadt am Meer.
Jonas, der Schlankere,
trägt seine kurzen Haare
in einem gestylten Seitenscheitel.
Oh.
* Er pfeift. *
(Beide) Gestylter Seitenscheitel.
Seither weisst du,
was für eine Frisur du hast.
Ich heisse Jonas, ich bin 26
und arbeite als Sachbearbeiter
beim Eidg. Hochschulinstitut
für Berufsbildung.
Seit meinem sechsten Lebensjahr
sehe ich nichts mehr.
Weil ich früher einmal gesehen habe,
erinnere ich mich gut an Farben.
Yves, der Stämmigere. Er hat ge-
scheitelte, hellbraune, kurze Haare.
Was?
Das hat mich damals schockiert.
Ich heisse Yves, bin 31
und komme aus dem Kanton Fribourg.
Von Beruf bin ich Radiomacher.
Schon seit meiner Geburt
sehe ich 2 %.
Ein weisser Stock
folgt einer Leitlinie.
Wir haben beim Fernsehen
die Sendung vorgeschlagen,
weil wir v.a.
dank zwei Dingen reisen können.
Dank der Technik und den Begegnun-
gen - Menschen, die uns helfen.
Wir wollten unbedingt zeigen,
wie wichtig es ist,
einander zu helfen, etwas zu zeigen,
miteinander zu sprechen.
Durch Begegnungen
kann man Grosses entstehen lassen.
Ein jüdischer Mann
im Gespräch mit Yves und Jonas.
(Lachend) Das finde ich super.
Wir werden auf Reisen
oft damit konfrontiert,
warum wir als Blinde oder
Sehbehinderte überhaupt reisen.
Die Leute denken,
wir hätten nichts davon.
Dabei können wir
die Stadt auch erleben.
Über Gerüche,
über Leute, die wir kennenlernen.
Dank der anderen Sinne und der
Begegnungen habe ich oft das Gefühl,
dass wir beim Reisen
beinahe mehr sehen als Sehende.
Jonas und Yves
berühren eine farbige Mauer.
Die beiden Freunde stehen neben-
einander und schauen in die Kamera.
In weisser Schrift:
"Blindflug", ein SRF-DOK-Film.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Verspielte Akkordeonmusik *
Das Ziel ist noch 50 m entfernt.
Schöne Musik, was?
- Ja.
Die habe ich für dich organisiert.
- Danke.
(Yves imitiert Bachelor Vujo)
Ich liess es mir für dich einfallen.
Sucht ihr etwas?
- Ja, das Tourismusbüro.
Das ist geradeaus und dann links.
Ist es noch weit?
- Nein, es ist gleich nebenan.
Das war jetzt eine präzise Angabe.
Das war wirklich ...
Ah, "das Ziel befindet sich
auf Ihrer linken Seite",
es vibriert, man sieht eine Türe.
* Er seufzt erleichtert. *
Achtung. Moment.
Du musst noch etwas weiter.
- Ah, ja. Wo denn? Ach, hier.
Vielen Dank.
Ist hier die Touristeninformation?
Ihr wollt da hin?
Dann müsst ihr die Treppe hoch.
Ich helfe euch.
Super.
- Venez.
Merci beaucoup.
Ich habe einfach
nach einer Türe gesucht
und die einer Telefonkabine
gefunden.
Es ist wirklich oft
die Alltagskomik ...
... die einfach passiert.
Das geschieht oft,
wenn wir unterwegs sind.
Das ist nicht so geplant.
Es gibt so viele Überraschungen.
Es passiert so vieles,
das man nicht steuern kann.
Kopfhörer.
Geht es so? Was nehmen wir?
Jerusalem?
Berlin?
Wollen wir ...
Nehmen wir Athen?
- Ich höre gar nichts.
Nicht? Können wir beginnen?
- Ja, sicher.
Okay, gut, es geht los. Achtung.
Hier ist Ihr Zimmer.
Und das ist Ihre Karte.
- Thank you.
Das ist der Schlitz für die Karte.
In welchen Schlitz?
- Hier.
Take it. We put it here.
Ah, for the ...
Das ist für den Strom.
Da, von links.
- Ah.
Stecken Sie die Karte rein.
Aha, like this.
Warten Sie kurz -
und dann öffnet sich die Türe.
Ah.
Hier ist das Badezimmer.
- Okay.
Kann ich den Rucksack hier ablegen?
- Ja, natürlich.
Thank you very much.
Geradeaus geht es zum Badezimmer
und zur Toilette.
Aha, ja, diese hier.
Gläser ...
... Wasser, Löffel ...
... Früchte.
Hier ist der Kaffee.
Ah, yes.
Wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen,
fragen Sie einfach.- Okay.
Athen reizte mich,
weil sowohl Jonas als auch ich,
das Weltgeschehen sehr verfolgen.
Die Nachrichten im Fernsehen
können wir nicht sehen,
darum haben wir auch nicht gesehen,
wie es in Griechenland aussieht.
Um zu sehen, zu erleben, zu riechen
und zu hören, wie es da ist,
muss man hierherkommen.
Hier kann man Athen riechen.
An Athen reizte mich einerseits
die Kulinarik,
andererseits die Geschichte.
Das hier war ein bedeutender Ort
für Philosophen, Denker
und für die Demokratie.
All die historischen Stätten inte-
ressierten mich besonders an Athen.
Es riecht gut nach Essen.
- Es ist gleich Mittagszeit.
So um 14 Uhr ...
Gehen wir links?
- Ja.
* Beschwingte Banjomusik *
Nach 300 m links abbiegen.
Hier würdest du geradeaus gehen?
- Ja.
Achtung,
nicht rechts hinunterfallen.
Bin ich nicht auf der Strasse?
- Nein.
Es hat zumindest Menschen.
- Ach, ja, gut.
Da hat es nun keine Angaben.
Es heisst einfach
"auf Leof. Vasilissis nach Westen",
aber es gibt keine Angaben
in Metern.
Verdammt. Was ist das?
Der Pfosten der Busstation?
Das muss das blaue Zeichen sein.
Ich habe es gespürt.
* Motorenlärm *
Oh, pardon.
Unmöglich, was hier alles rumsteht.
Sorry?- Wir können auf BlindSquare
nachschauen, wo es ist.
Könntest du das mal machen?
Ich versuche, zu fragen.
Sorry ... sorry ...
To go to the Lykabettus ...
Sorry ...
Die sind aber gesprächig.
Sorry, darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
- Ja.
Wir möchten auf den Lykabettus.
Geht es auf diese Seite
oder auf diese Seite?
In diese Richtung.
- Ah, in diese Richtung.
Vielen Dank.
- Gerne.
Wir wissen zumindest,
in welche Richtung wir gehen müssen.
Also hier, nicht da ...
So wie ich es verstanden habe,
in diese ...
In diese?
- In diese hier.
Ah, okay. Ja.
Wir haben uns schon verstanden.
Bist du sehend?
- Ja, neuerdings.
Wollen wir über die Strasse?
Nein, wir gehen
einfach mal gerade aus.- Okay.
Rauf.
Irgendetwas lässt mich vermuten,
dass ein Pfosten kommt.
Oh!
Hier links.
Warum, was haben wir Schönes?
Pfosten und Bäume.
Als Fussgänger
ist man hier zweite Kategorie.
Ja, fünfte.
- (Lachend) Okay.
Du kannst dich schon mal
psychisch darauf vorbereiten,
dass wir in 80 m links abbiegen.
- Ist gut, ja.
Wir haben auf dem Handy
verschiedene Navigations-Apps,
wie sie andere auch brauchen
in den Ferien - z.B. Google Maps.
Wir geben die Adresse oder
den Ort ein, an welchen wir wollen.
Heute haben wir das
nicht sehr genau gewusst,
weil es etwas schwierig ist
mit den griechischen Namen.
Unsere Sprachausgabe liest
die Schrift nicht wirklich gut vor.
So bereiten wir uns vor.
Wir machen uns auf den Weg,
gehen los und lassen uns lotsen.
Evtl. habe ich die obere Bergstation
als Ziel eingegeben.
Wahrscheinlich, aber hier
kann man vielleicht links abbiegen.
Wen interessiert's?
- Ein Auto.
Ist das die Bahn auf den Lykabettus?
Ah, great.
- You need the right track.
Ah, here. Thank you! Jonas?
- Yves, warte kurz!
Jonas?
Ja, warte.
Hier!
Ich bin hier noch
zwischen den Autos.
Du musst den Weg nehmen,
den ich genommen habe.- Ja.
So.
Hei, ei, ei!- Nächstes Mal
musst du besser parkieren.
Ich wollte zuerst hinten durch.
- Ach, sorry.
Wir haben auch
einen doofen Weg genommen.
Wenn wir uns
auf eine Reise vorbereiten,
recherchieren wir
in verschiedene Richtungen.
Internet, Wikipedia.
Podcasts runterladen ist auch gut,
um Dinge zu hören.
Auch TV-Sendungen
kann man sehen oder hören.
Ich glaube,
er hat die gleiche Ansicht wie du.
Wir wollten auf den Lykabettus,
weil es ein bedeutender Ort ist.
Man kann über die ganze Stadt sehen.
Obwohl wir sie nicht sehen,
ist es spannend,
weil es sicher viele Touristen hat,
die die Aussicht geniessen.
Wir haben von dieser Aussicht
auch etwas.
Wir hören die Stadt von weiter oben,
z.B. mit dem Verkehr.
* Sirene *
Man nimmt die Stadt anders wahr.
Es hat sich gelohnt, hinzugehen.
* Sirene *
Wollen wir ein Foto machen?
- Das könnten wir.
Dann müssen wir hier hinstehen.
Machen wir es selbst
oder fragen wir jemanden?
Wir machen es selbst.
Wie machen wir das?
Wir können das schon selbst.
Also, schau. Hier ist das Geländer.
- Oh, sorry.
Bist du bereit?
- Ja.
Was muss ich jetzt ...?
- (Lachend) "Was muss ich jetzt?"
"Rückseitig"? Nein, "vorderseitig".
- Vorderseitig ist besser.
Also, jetzt ...
- Warte.
Es sagt, ob die Gesichter
erkennt werden oder nicht.
Nein.
Ja, genau dort. Halt es mal hin.
So?
- Nein. Achtung.
Ein Gesicht hat es gefunden.
- Das ist viel.
Dich erkennt es evtl.
nicht als Mensch.
Zwei!
Es ist ein grosses Thema:
Reisen und Eltern.
Ich verstehe, dass es für
die Eltern nicht immer einfach ist,
uns loszulassen, reisen zu lassen.
Das Reisen wäre nicht das Problem.
Sie fanden, es wäre gut,
wenn jemand mitkommen würde,
der besser sieht als du -
also viel besser.
Das hast du mir nie gesagt.
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Aber es geht ja darum, gemeinsam
etwas zu erleben und zu entdecken.
Das macht Spass mit jemandem,
mit dem man sich gut versteht.
Treppe.
Ein Tritt?
- Ja, einer. Jetzt wieder.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Hörst du die Vögel?
- Ja.
Schön, nicht?
Komm, wir fragen jemanden.
- Nein, ich glaube, es ist gut.
Vorher meintest du auch,
du glaubst, es sei gut.
Es brauchte viel Glauben,
um nicht in den Himmel zu kommen.
Hier, links.
Nein.
Das ist kein guter Moment.
* Dynamische Musik *
How do you know
when it's a good moment to cross?
Ist das ein Haltehäuschen
oder ist ein Container?
Da ist eine Bank.
Ich glaube,es ist hier.
- Das glaube ich auch.
Etwas Blaues
habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Aber es könnte schon
ein Wartesaal sein.
Aber was ist das?
- Da ist die Haltestelle.
Ah, nein, das ist ...
Vorher gab es noch eine taktile
Linie - und jetzt nicht mehr.
Genau dann,
wenn man sie brauchen könnte.
Du hast das Gefühl,
hier fährt mal ein Bus vorbei?
Ja, jetzt ist zumindest
ein Taxi vorbeigefahren.
Achtung!
- Jetzt.
* Quietschende Bremsen *
Können wir da drüber?
- Komm mal.
Ja.
Hallo. Ist das die Busstation
vom Bus 126-550?
One, two, six ...
* Der Mann spricht griechisch. *
One, two, six. Wohin wollt ihr?
Zum Taktilen Museum.
But we don't know the ...
Der andere sagte doch etwas
von Interamerican.- Ja, genau.
Okay. Five ...
Five, five, zero ...
Es war dann halt so,
dass es nicht der richtige Bus war.
Wir suchten den Bus 550.
Aber er meinte,
wir sollten mitkommen.
Er hat uns in den Bus gezogen.
Wir sind sicher
keine 100 m gefahren.
Er hat uns
zur richtigen Station mitgenommen.
Guys!
- Yes?
Here.
- Here?
Yes.
- Okay, thank you.- Thank you.
Thank you.
Yves, hier.
- No, no. Let me.
Ich wollte sicher nicht
den Bus aufhalten.
Ich schätze die unkomplizierte Art,
die Flexibilität extrem,
dass sich keiner beschwert.
Irgendwie ...
Das haben wir vielleicht
nicht verstanden.
Ja, das stimmt.
Vielleicht haben wir es
wirklich nicht verstanden.
Das sind auch jene Momente, die mir
viel Kraft geben zum Reisen geben.
In den Situationen,
in denen es schnell gehen muss,
spürt man, ob einem die Leute
helfen oder nicht.
Great. Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
Super.
Thank you very much.
- Bye.
Hier kann man gut gehen.
Das gefällt mir.
(Mann) Hello.
- Hello.- Hello.
This way, please.
We're looking for
the Tactual Museum.
This way, not here.
Sorry?
- Not here.
Where is the museum?
You go straight from this way.
Hier hat es wieder Leitlinien.
-  Ja.
Das ist schon mal ein gutes Zeichen,
wenn es wirklich Leitlinien sind.
Das Ziel befindet sich
auf der linken Seite.
Jetzt ist es auch grün
Ah, jetzt.
- Hier könnte ... Nein.
Ist das ein Tor?
Es passt für mich zum Konzept,
dass man ein Museum für Blinde
und Sehbehinderte suchen muss.
Ich erlebe das auch oft in der
Schweiz oder an anderen Orten.
Dinge, Dienstleistungen,
die eigentlich speziell für Blinde
und Sehbehinderte gemacht sind,
sind oft gar nicht barrierefrei.
Oder manchmal scheitert es
an ganz kleinen Dingen,
dass man nicht hinkommt.
Jonas, hier.
- Was ist wohl hier?
Left. Okay?
* Er spricht griechisch. *
(Beide) 30 m.
Left.
* Er spricht griechisch. *
Grundsätzlich mögen wir es nicht,
wenn uns fremde Menschen anfassen,
zu denen wir nie Kontakt hatten.
Das ist dieser Plüschtiereffekt.
Oder der Zooeffekt:
Man meint, man könne alles anfassen.
Ich denke, das mag wohl kaum jemand.
Ich glaube,
das hier ist eine andere Kultur.
Die Leute versuchen unkompliziert,
uns zu helfen,
auch wenn sie weder Englisch
noch unsere Sprache reden.
Schlussendlich führt die Hilfe
zum Ziel. Darum ist es super.
* Stimmengewirr *
Da vorne ist noch ein Haus.
Warte. Vielleicht ... Good Morning.
Do you go to
the Lighthouse for the Blind?
Wir suchen das Taktile Museum.
Ich werde Sie zum Museum führen.
Das ist Frau Rokutaki,
die Vizepräsidentin.
Ah, hello! Freut mich, Yves.
- Jonas.
Ich führe Sie zum Museum, okay?
- Great, thank you!
Sind Sie auch sehbehindert?
Frau Rokutaki ist blind,
sie wurde blind geboren.
So, da sind wir also.
Lassen Sie mich ein paar Dinge
über das Museum sagen.
Das Taktile Museum
wurde 1984 gegründet.
Es ist eines von vier oder fünf
Museen dieser Art weltweit.
Das Spezielle hier ist,
dass wir alles berühren können.
Great.
Sie sind sehr charakteristisch
für die kykladische Zivilisation.
Sehen Sie, sie haben nur die Nase.
Look, the nose here.
It's very characteristic.
Sie haben keine Augen, keine Ohren,
keinen Mund.
Keine Haare?
- Keine Haare, nichts.
Vielleicht waren sie
mit leuchtenden Farben angemalt.
Oh, Entschuldigung.
Sie gehört dem Louvre-Museum.
Sie wurde auf Milos gefunden,
einer griechischen Insel.
Sie ist nackt.
Sie hat keine Arme.
Ihr Oberkörper ist nackt.
Unten trägt sie ein Kleid.
Aha, das ist ein Kleid.
- Ja.
Sehen Sie, und hier ist sie nackt.
Sie hat unsere Hände geführt,
aber nicht zu sehr
an das Objekt gedrückt.
Sie sagte nicht,
wo wir unbedingt tasten müssten.
Wir hatten selbst die Freiheit,
etwas zu spüren oder zu entdecken.
But she's not smiling.
Ich habe schön gefunden,
dass wir die Körper
zu dritt anfassen konnten.
Ich finde,
das braucht schon etwas Vertrauen.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich das mit jedem könnte.
Für sie war klar:
Die anderen schauen es ja auch an,
für uns ist das normal.
Wenn wir eine nackte Statue haben,
wissen wir, dass es Aphrodite ist.
Steht eine sehende Person
vor einer solchen Statue,
betrachtet sie sie als Ganzes.
Dann schaut sie die Details an,
wie was gemacht wurde,
wie der Kopf
und wie die Haare gemacht sind.
Bei uns ist es das Gegenteil.
Wir können mit der Hand
immer nur ein Detail erfassen.
Wir erfassen
ein Detail nach dem anderen -
so ergibt sich für uns
ein ganzes Bild der Statue.
Ah, yes.
- Close to the ... thighs.
* Dumpfe, glockige Klänge *
Oh, Musik.
- Ist das eine Steeldrum?
Etwas in dieser Art.
- Oder Pans. Eine Pfanne.
* Klassischer Gesang *
Oh, Gesang.
* Die Frau lacht. *
Wow. Great.
- Thank you, guys.
Wow.
Wonderful.
- Einfach ... wonderful.
Danke, das war
kein griechisches Lied.
Kein griechisches Lied?
- Nein, es ist meines.
Ah, it's yours? Wow!
Aber ich bin Griechin,
also ist es vielleicht doch
ein griechisches Lied.
This is for you.
Danke, ich werde es
in meine Hand nehmen.
Was ist das für ein Instrument?
- Wollen Sie versuchen, zu spielen?
Yes.
- It's possible?
Spielt man das mit den Armen?
- Ja.
Ich gebe es Ihnen in die Hand.
Hier, sehen Sie?
Und Sie hier.
Es ist hier.
- Ah.
Und hier ist das Instrument.
You can touch here.
Das sind die Noten.
Es ist aus Eisen.
* Dumpfe, glockige Klänge *
Ich glaube,
wir lassen wieder Sie spielen.
Das klingt besser.
Soll ich ihr auch noch etwas geben?
Thank you.
- You're welcome, guys.
Ein geiles Instrument.
- Ja, es ist cool.
Es ist super.
* Fröhliche Klavier-
und Akkordeonmusik *
Der Boden
ist nicht so stockfreundlich.
Nein, er ist etwas alt.
Die Blinden hatten es früher
nicht ganz einfach.
Geht es hier rechts?
- Ob es da etwas gratis gibt?
Da ist der Tempel.
Es scheint
ein recht grosses Haus zu sein.
Aha, oh, das ist eine Tour.
Sie sind mitten in einer Tour.
* Lachen *
Oh, sorry.- Das ist in Ordnung.
Wir hören ihm zu.
(Flüsternd) Oh, sorry.
- Kein Problem.
Brauchen Sie Hilfe?
Where are we now? At the temple?
- Yes.
Wir sind auf die Akropolis gegangen,
weil sie
ein sehr bekanntes Wahrzeichen ist.
Mich interessierte die Stimmung,
ob man etwas von den Steinen
spürt, die schon lange dort sind.
* Stimmengewirr *
Und wir biegen links ab.
Haben Sie überhaupt Zeit?
We don't want to steal your time.
Ich gehöre zu einer Gruppe.
(Beide) Oh, sorry!
Hier ist eine Absperrung.
Aber wenn Sie Ihre Hände etwas
ausstrecken, kommen Sie näher.
Hier ist die Mauer.
Das ist vermutlich vom Fries.
Oh, jemand hat gerufen.
- Es ist nicht erlaubt.
Okay.
Sollen wir weiter?
Was wir sehen,
ist der Rand des Parthenons.
Und es hat eins, zwei, drei, vier,
fünf, sechs, sieben, acht Säulen.
Und es sind immer noch Teile
der Skulpturen übrig.
Nur die ganze Mitte fehlt.
But it's absolutely magnificent.
Damit wir etwas mitbekommen,
muss man einfach das beschreiben,
was man sieht -
nicht mehr, nichts interpretieren.
Also möglichst konkret beschreiben,
was da ist, was man sieht.
Der Mann hat das sehr gut gemacht.
Hier ist es ein bisschen steinig.
Passen Sie gut auf.
Kannst du dir die Grösse vorstellen?
- Schwierig.
Wir schauen nun
in Richtung Erechtheion.
Ist es derselbe Stil?
Der Stil ist ähnlich,
die Spitzen der Säulen sind anders.
Sie haben - ich bin nicht sicher,
wie man sie nennt -
korinthische Verzierungen,
glaube ich.
Yves?
- Ja.
Hier dem Seil entlang.
- Da unten hört man etwas.
Links, oder?
- Da muss es hinaus führen.
Wir sind doch über
eine schmale Treppe gegangen.
Ja, genau.
- Dort müssten wir irgendwie ...
Wenn man die vielen Leute sieht,
fragt man sich schon,
warum die
immer noch mehr Kinder machen.
Wieso? Dichtestress?
- Es gibt genug Menschen.
Dichtestress, ja.
Um die Steine
des alten Griechenlands zu sehen,
ist die Akropolis
sicher ein Ausflug wert.
Aber idyllischere Orte
gibt es genügend andere.
Ich bin auch froh,
dass wir dort waren, aber ...
Ich habe es jetzt gesehen -
oder eben auch nicht.
* Yves kichert. *
Ja, nun hat es da ...
In der Nähe sollte es einen haben.
Da hört man doch etwas?
* Vogelzwitschern *
Hörst du das Pfeifen?
- Ja.
Das sind die Vögel.
- Achtung, da geht es runter!
Ui, ja!
Da geht es irgendwo rein.
Da geht es auch irgendwo rein.
Hier hat es lustige Sachen.
- Fragen wir ... Da leuchtet etwas.
Da. Hier.
Darf ich vorstellen:
Geldautomat, Jonas.
Jonas, Geldautomat.
- Herzlichen Dank.
Ich lasse dich machen.
- Vielleicht hat es Kopfhörer.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Hat es keine?
- Nein.
In der Schweiz haben jetzt fast alle
Bankomaten einen Kopfhöreranschluss.
Mit einer Sprachausgabe,
die einen durch das Menü leitet,
kann man
selbstständig Geld beziehen.
Hier gibt es das nicht - zumindest
nicht bei diesem Automaten.
Wir mussten uns helfen lassen.
Yes, sir.
Sie können den PIN eingeben.
- Thank you.
* Piepen *
Sie möchten Bargeld?
- Ja.
Wie viel?
- 200.
200.60.
Ah, okay.
Es gab auch schon Situationen,
in denen Leute den PIN-Code
für mich eingeben wollten.
Das war hier kein Thema.
Ich hatte den Eindruck,
dass er sich abgedreht
oder den Code mit der Hand verdeckt
hat, als ich ihn eingeben habe.
Bei ihm hatte ich einfach
ein gutes Gefühl.
Er hat gesagt, ich solle das Geld
zählen und gefragt, ob alles stimmt.
Das hat extrem viel Vertrauen
gegeben.
Also, 200.60 Fr.
- Ah, okay.
Ob das wohl stimmt?
- Ja, ja.
Ah, sind das drei 50er-Noten?
- Ja.
Thank you very much.
- Riechen Sie die Noten?
Nein, ich sehe die Zahlen.
Möchten Sie auch einmal riechen?
- No, no.
Schweizer Franken
riechen besser als Euros.
Ja, ganz bestimmt!
Sorry, Anafi ist in dieser Richtung?
Anafi? Anafiotika.
- Anafiotika, sorry.
Gehen Sie diese Strasse runter,
links - und dann rechts.
Dort ist
ein weiterer Fussgängerstreifen.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
Danke für Ihre Hilfe.
Ich muss noch rasch wegräumen.
(Lachend) Ich liebe diese Frage.
In der Schweiz hätte ich mich
so genervt über diese Frage.
Riechst du am Geld?
- Nein, er hat nicht ...
Das ist lustig,
er hat es nicht so gefragt.
Die Schweizer fragen immer,
ob wir am Geld riechen.
Wie erkennst du das Geld?
Riechst du daran, Yves?
Geld stinkt, wie du ja weisst.
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik,
Stimmengewirr *
(Mann) Sweet coconuts.
Ah, you're selling them.
Jetzt fährt er durch.
Uh, es riecht speziell.
- Das sind Erdbeeren.
Ah, ja.
Dann bezahlst du.
Wir entscheiden auch,
wie viel Geld wir geben.
Auch Kirschen?
- No, thank you.
Die sind aber lecker.
Bedien dich.
- Darf ich noch eines nehmen?
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik *
Es riecht schon etwas nach Meer.
- Evtl. fahren wir dem Meer entlang.
Wir sind an der Endstation.
Ihr könnt mit mir kommen.
Folgt mir.
- (Beide) Okay.
Oh, sorry.
- No worries.
Jonas?
Das ist schnell gegangen, nicht?
- Ja.
Sind Sie hier
auch schon im Meer gewesen?
Ich habe Angst zu schwimmen,
weil ich keinen schönen Körper habe.
Keinen schönen Körper?
Den habe ich auch nicht.
Die Menschen würden alle wegrennen.
Bei mir auch.
Nein! Sie sind jung, Sie sind schön.
- Thank you.
Nur er ist schön.
Sie auch, keine Angst.
Aber ich bin alt, alles hängt.
* Sie lachen. *
Da hast du ja jemanden gefunden,
Yves, was?
* Beide lachen herzhaft. *
Okay.
Sie sind super.
And you are here.
Jetzt einen kleinen
Schritt neben deinen Freund.
Thank you very much.
Es war sehr schön,
euch kennengelernt zu haben.
Gleichfalls. Danke für Ihre Hilfe.
Have a nice time.
Bye.
All the best.
- (Beide) You, too.
* Beide kichern. *
Ja, darum geht es ja.
Von Athen wird mir
die Freundlichkeit der Leute
am meisten in Erinnerung bleiben.
Die Menschen,
die einem geholfen haben.
Die Gemütlichkeit in den Strassen,
mit den Cafés
und den Strassenmusikern.
Bezeichnend für die Stadt finde ich
die Hilfsbereitschaft der Menschen.
Sie machen sich keine Gedanken
darüber, wie sie helfen können
oder dass sie etwas falsch machen
könnten - sie helfen einfach.
* Sanfte, griechische Sirtakimusik *
Deine Kollegin, die du kennengelernt
hast, die uns das Meer gezeigt hat.
Ich habe mich wenigstens mit ihr
unterhalten. Du hast nur gelacht.
Na ja,
ich war halt etwas im Hintergrund.
Sehr, ja. Dafür hat sie dich
am Ende schön geküsst.
Ja, da bin ich ziemlich erschrocken.
- Wie war das?
Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet.
Aber daran sieht man eben auch,
dass alle Begegnungen
ganz unterschiedlich waren.
Sie war sehr offen und hatte
überhaupt keine Berührungsängste.
Vielleicht
liegt es auch an der Kultur.
An gewissen Orten sind es sich
die Menschen eher gewohnt,
andere zu berühren
und keine Berührungsängste zu haben.
Das ist ja irgendwie auch schön.
Es ist schon interessant.
In Athen hat uns ja
der eine Typ fast umarmt.
Ich gebe es zu, wenn das
in der Schweiz passieren würde,
würde ich wohl sagen:
"Geht's noch?"
Dort machte es mir nichts aus,
weil es eben
einfach diese Kultur ist.
Nach der Ausstrahlung der Sendungen
habe ich oft gehört,
dass uns Leute auf der Strasse
nicht geholfen hätten.
V.a. auch in Berlin.
Aber ich glaube,
das ist eine ganz andere Kultur.
Man hat extrem gespürt, dass die
Leute viel ruppiger, direkter sind.
Vielleicht nicht herzlich,
dafür weiss man, woran man ist.
Friedrichstrasse?
- Ja.
Oh, jetzt ist es auf der 2.
303 m auf der 2.
Stopp! Hier stoppen!
Was ist das wohl?
- Ich verstehe es auch noch nicht.
Hat es hier ein Lichtsignal?
Jetzt gehen einige los.
Ich glaube, wir können gehen.
Ich freue mich, dass ich in Berlin
Dinge entdecken darf.
Die Geschichte. Etwa die Berliner
Mauer, die mich sehr interessiert.
Mich interessiert, wie sehr die
Menschen heute noch geprägt sind.
Hier leben so viele unterschiedliche
Menschen auf kleinem Raum zusammen.
Ist man hier etwas toleranter?
Fällt man hier etwas weniger auf,
wenn man eine Behinderung hat?
Oh, nein.
- Achtung!
Das war denkbar ungünstig.
- Jetzt?- Ja.
* Entspannte Musik *
Hier ist wohl deine Brücke.
- Ja, ja.
Ist das schön.
- Jetzt kommt's gut.
Wie weit ist es noch?
- 80 m.
Und gleich rechts abbiegen.
- Pardon.- In 10 m.
Ja, komm.
Hier neben dieser Maschine.
Die hört ja wohl jeder -
sogar ein Fernsehjournalist.
Ist gut, wenn wir ...
- Ich rufe mal an.
* Hämmerndes Rattern *
Guten Morgen, Herr Arnold.
Hier ist Yves Kilchör.
Wir sind hier
in der Nähe einer Maschine.
Ich weiss nicht, ob Sie uns sehen.
Yves?
- Super. Vielen Dank.
Wir sind zu spät.
- Tja.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Mit wem habe ich telefoniert?
- Mit mir. Hallo. Guten Morgen.
Ich bin Adrian.
- Freut mich, Yves.
Wir duzen uns, das geht einfacher.
Adrian.
- Jonas. Hallo, Adrian.
Freut mich sehr.
- Freut mich.
Schön, seid ihr in Berlin.
Wir beobachten beide
das Weltgeschehen.
Deutschland spielt momentan
bei vielen Themen eine grosse Rolle.
Da ist immer wieder der
Korrespondent im Fernsehen wichtig,
der die Situation einordnet
und etwas zur Geschichte erzählt.
Dürfen wir bei dir einhängen?
- Natürlich.
Wir haben ihn getroffen,
weil wir das Gefühl hatten,
dass er uns ein Berlin zeigen kann,
wie kaum jemand anderes.
Die Distanz zwischen dem Kanzleramt
von Frau Merkel
und der Schweizer Botschaft
beträgt etwa 50 m.
Okay.
Eine breite Strasse
liegt dazwischen.
Die Schweizer Botschafterin,
bzw. ist es aktuell ein Botschafter,
kann Frau Merkel
ins Büro schauen.
* Yves und Jonas lachen. *
Der Reichstag ist,
ich würde mal sagen,
etwa drei- bis viermal so gross
wie das Bundeshaus in Bern.
Ah, ja. So gross?
Ich stelle ihn mir
wie die Akropolis vor.
Da gibt es auch dieses Dreieck.
- Genau, genau.
Man kann es tatsächlich vergleichen.
Eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit ist da.
Das hier ist relativ neu.
Hier oben sind die alten Mauern.
Ah, ja.
Es ist ein grosser Unterschied.
Ja, stimmt.
So fühlt sich deutsche Politik an.
Hart.
- Knallhart.
- Rauh und steinig.
- Genau.
Siehst du, ich habe sie
auch noch nie angefasst.
Den Sandstein spürt ihr sofort.
- Mhm.
Wie das Berner Münster.
- Ja, genau.
Oder?
- Ich würde es schon sagen.
An einigen Stellen
hat es auch noch Einschusslöcher
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Ah, sicher?
- Wirklich?
Ja.
Es war eine super Idee von Adrian,
dass er uns diese Mauer zeigte
und wir sie spüren konnten.
Auch die Erklärung dazu, dass sie
den Zweiten Weltkrieg überlebte.
Ich zeige euch
die "Aufsagerposition",
den Ort der Liveschaltungen.
Warst du gestern dort?
Ja, gestern war ich auch dort.
Das ist auch ein Grund,
warum wir reisen:
Dass wir das,
was wir in der "Tagesschau" hören -
wir hören sie ja meistens -
auch spüren, riechen oder ...
erleben.
Es wird dann für euch
dreidimensional.
Ja, genau.
* Dynamische Musik *
Und du stehst dann ungefähr so ...
Genau, ich stehe eigentlich
mit dem Rücken zum Reichstag,
so wie ihr jetzt steht.
Da direkt vor euch
steht der Kameramann
und filmt in meine Richtung -
oder dir jetzt ins Gesicht -
und hinten sieht man schön
den Reichstag.
Gut, wir machen mal eine Frage.
Eine kurze Einschätzung:
Deutschland
im Vergleich zur Schweiz.
Wie sind die ersten Eindrücke
aus Berlin?
Ich muss warten. Es gibt immer
eine Verzögerung, bis du sprichst.
* Adrian und Yves lachen. *
Genau.
Die Deutschen sind sicher direkter,
das haben wir schon gemerkt.
Uns gefallen v.a. auch
die Schweizer in Berlin sehr gut.
Besser hättest du das
nicht sagen können.
* Lachen *
* Dynamische Musik *
Wir gehen auf diese Seite.
Da oben ist mein Coiffeur.
Du bist ja bekannt für deine Frisur.
(Lachend) Man sagt es.
Wie hast du ihn gefunden?
Er befindet sich in meinem Quartier.
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass Adrian von Anfang an checkte,
was wir wollen.
Das fand ich cool.
Er hat uns sein Berlin gezeigt.
Sehr schön, danke.
Er war die beste Art
von Reiseführer.
Jonas,
kommst du etwas mehr zur Mitte hin?
Für die Sehenden sei es ja wichtig,
nicht nur uns zuzuhören,
sondern auch zu sehen,
wie es dort ausgesehen hat.
Meine Mutter ist ein grosser Fan
von Adrian Arnold.
Ohne Foto hätte ich mich
kaum nach Hause gewagt.
Voilà.
- Super!- Danke.
Das waren die Berliner Skater Boys.
Warte, warte, warte!
Du bist auf der Strasse.
Das ist die Tramschiene.
Du denkst, wir können auch gehen?
- Ich denke schon.
Aber links von dir ist ein Tram.
- Ist es ein Tram?
Da kann man drücken.
* Autohupe *
Hast du gedrückt?
- Ja.
* Piepen *
Komm, wir gehen! Oh, oh.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht mehr grün.
Nein, aber es gehen noch Leute
vor uns. Sorry.
* Klackern der Blindenstöcke *
Links hat es wieder Graffiti.
Es kann sein, dass es die schon ist.
- Die Mauer?
Es ist ein längerer Abschnitt.
Siehst du etwas von den Bildern?
Die Bilder kann ich nicht erkennen,
aber ich sehe die Farben.
Reich mir mal deine Hand.
- Ja.
Da unten ist Gelb.
Noch weiter unten ist Weiss.
Da ist Weiss. Ein gelber Streifen,
ein blauer Streifen. Gelb, Gelb ...
Ich habe noch eine Vorstellung
von Farben. Ich kann mich erinnern.
Bis ich sechs Jahre alt war,
habe ich gesehen,
deshalb kann ich mir unter Blau,
Gelb, Rot etwas vorstellen.
Als Kind sieht man die Welt
auch noch etwas anders.
Daher kann ich nicht sagen,
wie gut ich es mir vorstellen kann.
Ich habe für mich ein Bild
und das ist das Wichtigste.
Z.T. sehe ich sogar Licht.
Oder wenn die Sonne scheint habe ich
das Gefühl, dass es heller wird.
Aber das ist vermutlich Einbildung.
Wenn ich Wärme auf der Haut spüre,
muss es wohl die Sonne sein.
Ähm, ja ...
Von daher habe ich wohl das Gefühl,
dass es hell ist -
oder dass es heller sein müsste.
Da ist etwas geschrieben.
(Langsam) Ein Mahn...
Hallo?
Darf ich Ihnen die Hand geben?
Ich bin Günter Schäfer.
Guten Tag.
- Ich bin der Autor dieses Bildes.
Ah, okay.
Ich lese den Text vor.
- Ja.
"Diese Flagge
basiert auf dem Grundgedanken
von Frieden und Einheit
aller Völker."
"Sie ist eine Auseinandersetzung
mit dem Erbe
aller deutschen Generationen
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg."
"Ein Mahnmal
gegen jede faschistische Tendenz:
Reichskristallnacht,
9. November 1938."
"Mauerfall, 9. November 1989."
Ah!
Also einmal das dunkelste Datum:
die Kristallnacht.
Und einmal das Datum:
Freude, die Mauer öffnet.
Wann haben Sie das gemacht?
- Im März 1990.
Kommen Sie noch oft vorbei?
Ab und zu. Der Inhalt des Bildes
gefällt nicht jedem.
Es wird sehr oft heftig zerstört.
- Ja.
Bis dato habe ich es
62-mal restauriert.
(Yves und Jonas) Wow!
Es war ein grosser Zufall, dass wir
Herrn Schäfer getroffen haben.
V.a. war es auch schön,
wie er es vorgelesen hat
und uns das Bild erklärt hat.
Das war das Beste daran.
Nichts gegen deine Erklärungskünste,
aber es war schon etwas besser.
Ich lese dir nie mehr etwas vor.
* Sanfte, schwungvolle Musik *
(Durchsage) Sehr geehrte Fahrgäste,
der Zug ...
Yves?
- Ja?
Ich glaube, diese Bahn ist gut.
- Nehmen wir die?
Ja, die nehmen wir.
- Also, einsteigen.
Ich hoffe es.
* Sanfte Motorengeräusche *
Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist der-
selbe Zug- oder Motorenhersteller,
wie bei gewissen RBS-Bahnen.
Da ist etwas dran.
Einfach eine viel stärkere Variante.
- Ja.
(Durchsage) Ausstieg ...
- (Yves gleichzeitig) ... links.
Oh, schön.
- Das dachte ich mir.
Lassen wir erst
die anderen aussteigen.
Aber nicht zu lange warten.
Gehen wir?
- Ja.
Oh, da ist ein Pfosten. Sorry.
Hast du dich beim Pfosten
entschuldigt?- Nein, bei dir.
Das ist eine lange Unterführung,
was?
Ja, wirklich.
Müssen wir bis zum Ende gehen?
Gut?
Jetzt!
Die Strassen sind etwas kleiner.
Wir sind schon etwas ausserhalb.
Es ist etwas ländlich hier, was.
- Ja.
Ich bin Henrik, grüsst euch.
- Freut mich, Yves.
Jonas, freut mich.
- Super.
Mögt ihr euch festhalten?
- Wir suchen die Tandemgruppe.
Weil Berlin eine Fahrradstadt ist,
dachten wir, es wäre cool,
mit einem Tandem zu fahren.
Tandem oder Fahrrad fahren
gibt einem eine gewisse Freiheit,
das Tempo zu spüren.
Man spürt den Wind.
Das erlebt man zu Fuss nicht so.
* Stimmengewirr *
(Alle) Hallo.
Anne kommt gleich auf euch zu.
Sie sieht auch nichts.
Jonas, freut mich.
- Hallo.
Hallo, ich bin Yves. Freut mich.
Das ist jetzt blöd gefragt:
Wer von euch ist der Leichtere?
Jonas.- Das wäre ich.
- Der geht zu Jörg.
Rechtes Pedal oben.
- Ja.
* Stimmengewirr *
So, dann fahren wir los.
- Ja, gerne.
Du sagst einfach, wenn ich mehr
oder weniger pedalen soll.
* Entspannte, ruhige Musik,
leise Gespräche *
Wir erreichen gleich einen Berg.
- Ja.
Das ist ein Trümmerberg.
Da haben die Nazis
eine Parteischule gebaut
und der ganze Trümmerschutt
des Zweiten Weltkriegs
wurde hier aufgehäuft.
- Wow.
Wie bist du zum Tandemfahren
gekommen?
Als ich vor fünf Jahren
in Rente gegangen bin,
habe ich per Zufall davon gelesen.
Haben wir den Bergpreis?
- Ja, genau.
Ja!
Auf dieser Tandemtour haben wir ein
ganz anderes Berlin kennengelernt.
Ich wusste nicht,
dass es in Berlin so viel Wald hat.
So, wie sie uns davon erzählt haben,
sind sie wohl sehr stolz,
dass Berlin allgemein
viele Grünflächen hat.
* Entspannte Musik *
* Die Männer sprechen ausgelassen
durcheinander und lachen. *
Danke, dass es geklappt hat.
- Es war eine grosse Freude.
Prost!
- Auf den Rütlischwur!
Alle zusammen in die Mitte.
(Alle) Prost!
Auf die Schweizer!
Der typische Berliner
ist sehr offen, zugänglich,
auch ansprechbar und zugewandt, aber
er ist eben auch vorlaut und frech.
Man darf sich
von dieser robusten Ansprache,
die man oft bekommt auf Fragen,
nicht einschüchtern lassen.
In dieser Hinsicht ist Berlin
echt eine supertolle Stadt.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Hupen *
* Krächzen und Vogelzwitschern *
Es ist ganz schön hier.
Es ist idyllisch
zwischen den Bäumen.
Es wirkt nicht
wie ein Touristen-Hotspot.
Wo geht es wohl durch?
- Vielleicht ist geschlossen.
Genau.
Links, oder?
- Nein, links geht es nicht weiter.
Eher rechts.
- Da.
(Mann) Ja, das sieht gut aus.
- Ist das der Modellpark?
Ja, herzlich willkommen.
- Ah! Danke. Hallo.
Das kostet pro Person 3 Euro.
Du kriegst dann zwei schöne Karten.
(Beide) Super.
- Ich bezahle.
Nein, ich habe es bereit.
Du kennst das Geld nicht so.
He! Das sind fünf, oder?
- Das sind zehn.
Siehst du.
- Das passt.
Hier einmal die Karten.
- Super.
Waren Sie schon mal bei uns?
- (Beide) Nein.
Wäre es möglich, dass uns jemand
ein, zwei Gebäude zeigt,
die wir ertasten könnten?
Aber gerne, natürlich.
Im Modellpark
haben wir die Möglichkeit,
dass wir Gebäude und
Sehenswürdigkeiten ertasten können.
Die Gebäude sind in echt so gross,
dass wir z.B. nur einen kleinen Teil
der Mauern ertasten können
wie beim Reichstag.
Dann ist es toll,
wenn man eine Übersicht erhält
oder möglichst
das ganze Gebäude erfassen kann.
Da schreiten wir jetzt
auf das Brandenburger Tor zu.
Mit der Quadriga, den Säulen
und den beiden Nebengebäuden.
Dahinter ist der Streitwagen
mit der Göttin
und dem Adler obendrauf
als Siegeszeichen.
Die Flügel.
- Das hier ist der Adler.
* Entfernte Kirchenglocken *
Es ist spannend: Ich hatte erwartet,
dass das Brandenburger Tor
ziemlich gross und pompös ist.
Jetzt bin ich fast etwas enttäuscht.
Im Vergleich zu anderen Gebäuden
fühlt sich das Tor nach nichts an.
Gehen wir zum nächsten Modell?
- Ja.- Gerne.
Das ist ein grosses Gebäude.
- Das ist der Reichstag.
Ach so, da haben wir ihn wieder.
- Genau.
Da stehen wir auf der grossen Wiese
vor dem Gebäude?
Genau, da stehen wir und schauen
direkt von vorne auf den Reichstag.
Es ist cool ...
Die Mauer ist schön nachgebildet.
Die konnten wir bereits spüren.
Da spürte man Steinbilder
oder Steinplatten,
die man hier auch sehr gut spürt.
- Ja, genau.
Die Verknüpfung von dem,
was Adrian erzählt hat,
und dem, was man da erlebt hat ...
Adrian erzählte, über dem Eingang
stehe "dem deutschen Volke".
Dass wir das noch spüren konnten,
war schon toll.
Eine schöne Schrift. So geschwungen.
... deutschen ... Vol...ke.
* Sanfte Jazzmusik *
Es geht immer noch weiter.
- Das ist wahnsinnig.
Hier ist jetzt Schluss.
- Wahnsinnig.
Hier biegen wir ab.
- Ja.
Zu Beginn dachten wir, er führe uns
vielleicht, weil Kameras dabei sind.
Aber als sie aus waren und sich
nicht mehr für uns interessierten,
ging er mit uns weiter
und zeigte und noch x Gebäude.
Er hat sich unglaublich viel Zeit
für uns genommen, das war toll.
Yves?
- Ja.
Wollt ihr zur U-Bahn?
- (Beide) Genau.
Ich gehe mit euch mit.
Die Kreuzung ist ziemlich gross.
Kann ich mich am Arm festhalten?
- Ja, klar. Wollt ihr beide?
Geht das?
- Ja, klar.
Wo wollt ihr denn hin?
- Zu Curry 36 an der ...
Oh! Natürlich!
- Kennen Sie es?
Jetzt, los!
Ja, Curry 36 kenne ich. Da ist der
Burgermeister, der ist auch lecker.
Jetzt müsst ihr nach rechts.
Was sollen wir eher nehmen?
Die Schlange ist momentan sehr,
sehr lang. Es dauert mind. 1 Std.
Ah, okay.
- Jetzt ist grün.
Vielen Dank. Einen schönen Tag.
- Vielen Dank.
Müssen wir hier anstehen?
- (Mann) Ja, genau so.
(Beide) Super.
Ist die Schlange lang?
- (Mann) Nein, es geht.
(Frau) Für Curry 36 geht's.
- Okay.
Hast du dich schon mit der
Speisekarte vertraut gemacht?
Ich denke, es gibt Pizza.
Yves?
- Ah, da.
Nein, nein, alles gut.
- Ah, sorry.
I'm your helper.
- Ah, super.
Yves!
- Ja.
Okay. Did you order already?
- (Beide) Ja, wir haben bestellt.
Ach, euer Essen ist bereit.
Yves, komm!
Langsam. Noch drei Schritte.
Stopp!
- Okay.
Hand ausstrecken, da ist der Tisch.
- Super, vielen Dank.
Yves?
- Ja.
Hier ist die Gabel.
Hier endet der Teller.
Vorne ist die Wurst,
hinten die Pommes.
Vielen Dank.
- Kein Problem.
Super, vielen Dank.
- Einen schönen Tag.
Danke, einen schönen Tag.
- Tschüss.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Mal probieren.
- Ich glaube, bei dir ist jemand.
Ehrlich gesagt
war die Currywurst ...
... nicht so speziell.
Es war halt einfach Ketchup,
Curry und eine Wurst.
Eine ganz normale, simple Bratwurst
mit ein paar Pommes frites
mag ich genauso gerne
wie diese Currywurst.
Noch 303 m auf der 2.
60 m auf der 12.
Da ist ein Hubschrauber.
* Rattern der Triebwerke *
Ich nehme an,
dass es hier links ist.
Es sei ja ziemlich gross.
- Ja.
Es muss ja so etwas
wie ein Feld sein, oder?
Ja. Es steht noch 90 m,
aber ich denke, es ist hier links.
Versuchen wir es.
- Sollen wir es probieren?
Ja, schau.
- Ach, ja.
Schau, da sind schon die Blöcke.
Ach,
sie sind nicht immer gleich hoch.
Nein,
Man kann sozusagen Teil
des Holocaust-Mahnmahls sein.
Mann kann hineingehen,
es ist eine Art Labyrinth.
Es ist spannend, das zu entdecken,
die Grösse zu erfassen.
Kommst du nicht mehr hoch?
- Doch, mit dem Stock.
Ja, stimmt.
Ich gehe einfach geradeaus.
- Also gut.
* Klackern der Blindenstöcke *
* Ruhige Akkordeonmusik *
Herr Jonas?
Jonas?
* Vereinzelte Stimmen *
Herr Jonas?
* Angespannte Musik,
dumpfe, pulsierende Schläge *
Jonas?
Hier!
Hier, hier, hier, hier!
Hier, hier, hier!
Ah.
Da.
- Wo?
- Ich finde dich fast nicht.
Hier.
- Was?
Ich blieb stehen. Ich dachte,
wir finden wir uns sonst nie wieder.
Komm!
- Wohin?
Hier hinein.
Ich finde die Grösse,
die grosse Fläche so wichtig.
Dass das so viel Platz einnimmt.
Ich finde auch, wenn man
dort drin ist und sich überlegt,
wem das gewidmet ist ...
Es passt einfach sehr gut.
Es hat
einen sehr symbolischen Charakter.
* Verspielte Musik *
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe Berlin von seinen ver-
schiedensten Seiten kennengelernt.
Mir ist Berlin nun nicht mehr nur
als graue Stadt in Erinnerung,
sondern mit dieser Landschaft ...
Mir bleibt die Mauer
extrem in Erinnerung,
das Treffen mit dem Künstler.
Das brachte mir die ganze Geschichte
etwas näher, machte sie fassbarer.
Es hat mir mehr gegeben,
als ich erwartet habe.
Das zeigt,
dass man Berlin x-mal besuchen kann
und doch noch nicht alles
gesehen hat.
Es reizt mich,
bald wieder hierherzukommen.
* Die Musik endet abrupt. *
In Berlin könnten wir wohl wohnen
und ziemlich selbstständig leben.
Mhm.
Wobei ich überrascht war, wie gut
die Metro in Athen ausgebaut ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Manchmal hat es einfach wenig Platz
auf dem Gehsteig.
Und er wird anders genutzt
als für Fussgänger, aber sonst ...
Dafür standen dir in Jerusalem
die Bäume im Weg.
Die hingen so raus.
- Das stimmt, ja.
Aber viele Sachen ...
- So kleine Inseln.
Mit Bäumen?
Ja, ich glaube, es hat hier Bäume.
Ah ja, es hat Bäume.
Tatsächlich hat es Bäume hier.
Praktisch, einen Hut zu tragen.
- Ja.
* Glasscheppern *
Huiuiui.
- Hoppla.
Solche Poller mögen sie auch,
an denen man sich
die Beine stossen kann.
Ah, du meinst, die stehen da,
damit man sich die Beine stösst?
Ja, ich glaube, die wurden
extra für uns organisiert.
Wir gehen nach Jerusalem,
weil wir herausfinden wollen,
wie das in der Stadt so ist,
in der die verschiedenen Religionen
zu Hause sind
und aus der
v.a. über Konflikte berichtet wird.
Wir wollen sehen,
wie gut die Leute da zusammenleben.
Einfach weitergehen.
- Geradeaus?
Ja, aber ich bin auch nicht sicher.
- Wollen wir es probieren?
Hello.
- Ja?
- Sorry?
Braucht ihr Hilfe?
Wir gehen in die Altstadt.
Ist das hier oben?
Altstadt?
- Is that correct here?
Nein, nein. Da lang.
- Okay, this way.
Wartet, die Strasse.
- Ja.
Er sagt, wir sollen gleich hier
gegen links über die Strasse.
Wartet. Jetzt könnt ihr gehen.
Now?
Hier hat es
so eine Art Zebrastreifen.
Ist er noch hier?
- Ja.
Also wer er? Er?
- Oder es.
And now straight on?
Er ist weg.
- Ah, er ist weg.
Oh nein, jetzt konnten wir uns
nicht mal mehr bedanken.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Das ist es wahrscheinlich.
Wollen wir jemanden fragen?
Sorry.
- Sorry.
Jetzt sind wir wahrscheinlich drin.
Jetzt sind wir wohl in der Altstadt.
Sorry, ist da das Jaffator?
- Genau.
Willkommen in Palästina.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you.
- Das hier war einmal Palästina.
Ah, und jetzt sind wir
im christlichen Viertel?
Jetzt ist es
israelisch-palästinensisch.
Wollen wir noch wegen der SIM-Karte
fragen?- Ah, ja.
Wo können wir eine SIM-Karte kaufen?
- Fürs Handy?
Ja.
- Kommt, ich helfe euch.
Can I ...
Sorry, can I hold you like that?
Ist hier das christliche Viertel?
Links ist das christliche Viertel
und rechts das armenische.
Für uns ist es wichtig,
dass wir überall Internet haben,
weil wir oft mit dem Handy
navigieren und Dinge nachschlagen.
SIM card?
- A SIM card, yes.
Eine israelische SIM-Karte
wollt ihr?- Yes.
Für wie viele Tage?
- Acht.
Have a seat. Sit here.
Okay, du kannst ein bisschen sitzen.
Er muss euch
einen fairen Preis machen.
Hoffentlich.
Er haut euch
nur ein bisschen übers Ohr.
* Lachen *
So, mein Freund,
kann ich dein Handy haben?
Yes.
Soll ich ihm mein Phone geben?
- Ja.
Das ist schon gut, oder?
Ich finde,
es braucht schon Vertrauen.
Aber man hat es vielleicht gemerkt:
Man muss versuchen herauszufühlen,
ob es die Person gut meint
oder eher nicht.
Was ist das Passwort?
Fünf, sieben, fünf, drei.
Seid ihr zufrieden mit ihm?
Ja, schon fast.
Die Basis des Ganzen
ist unser Vertrauen in die Leute.
Wenn wir das nicht hätten,
würden wir schon gar nicht gehen.
* Rasante Musik *
Das ist wohl so etwas wie
die Bahnhofstrasse von Jerusalem.
Ja.
Ui, sorry.
Yves?
- Jonas?
Hier.
- Hier bist du.
Hat dich jemand berührt?
- Ja.
Das ist wohl eine Art Markthalle.
* Lachen *
Nicht, dass sie uns noch nachkommen.
Schon ein bisschen mehr ...
- Überdacht.
Jetzt ist es wieder offen.
Der Boden ist anders,
hast du es gemerkt?- Ja, stimmt.
Er ist viel glatter.
Ah, verkauft der hier etwas?
Verkaufen Sie hier etwas?
- Nein.
Geht es hier lang zur Klagemauer?
Nein, ihr müsst hier runter
und dann links.
Wenn ihr möchtet,
kann ich euch hinbringen?
Thank you. Okay. Can I hang on?
- Yes.
Shoulder, arm.
- Thank you. That's great.
Nice to meet you, be careful!
- Nice to meet you, bye.
Wie heissen Sie?
- Jerome.
Sind Sie jüdisch?
- Nein.
Palästinensisch?
Armenisch?
- Nein.
Christlich?
- Ja.- Aha.
* Stimmengewirr,
Durchsagen in einem Lautsprecher *
* Muezzin-Rufe *
* Rhythmische Trommelschläge *
Es hat viele Leute hier.
Ja. Das ist schon mal
ein gutes Zeichen, oder?
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch
durch die Sicherheitsdetektoren.
Man müsse sich angemessen kleiden.
Ja,
deshalb trage ich eine lange Hose.
Ja.
Es gibt verschiedene Eingänge,
nicht?
Ja, durch welchen
sind wir wohl gegangen?
* Hupen *
- Oh, Achtung!
Ich glaube,
wir gehen hier auf der Strasse.
Ah, ja, hier. Oh!
Yves?- Ja?
- Gehen wir hier lang?
Steht, wir sollen
weiter rechts gehen?- Nein.
* Schnelle Trommelschläge,
rhythmisches Klatschen *
Oh,
jetzt kommen wir mitten ins Fest.
* Trommeln, Gesang *
Jonas?
Ah, hier.
- Yves?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es geradeaus oder links geht.
Weisst du das?
- Nein.
Da vorne ist irgendetwas.
Etwas aus Holz.
- Ah, das ist ein Konstrukt.
Was ist das wohl?
- Ein Gerüst.
Ah, wird hier hinten gebaut?
Hier, nicht?
Ich glaube, hier ist ein Eingang.
- Oder ist es ein Ausgang?
Soll ich mal fragen?
- Ja, komm.
Sorry.
- Ja?
Wollt ihr zur Klagemauer?
- Ja, genau.
Nimm meine Hand, mein Freund.
Nimm meine Hand.
Sind Sie auch ein Besucher?
Or are you working here?
Nein, ich bin Tourguide.
Dürfen wir
mit dem Hut zur Klagemauer?
Ja, man braucht einfach etwas im ...
nicht im, aber auf dem Kopf.
Okay.
Ihr könnt aber auch
eine Kippa haben, wenn ihr wollt.
One kippa for you.
Okay, my friend. Okay.
And one kippa for you.
- Thank you.
Den Hut könnt ihr auf die Kippa tun.
Okay?
Okay.
Aha, like that?
- Yes.
Take my hand and go with me please.
Hast du ihn einfach darüber gezogen?
Ja, ich verstehe nicht,
warum wir die Kippa ...
Aber das hat sicher einen Grund.
- Das ist fürs Gefühl.
Es war gut,
dass wir eine Kippa bekommen haben,
so konnte ich mal spüren,
wie die überhaupt aussieht.
Ich dachte immer,
es sei ein etwas grösseres Hütchen.
Und nicht, dass es nur so einen
kleinen Teil des Kopfs bedeckt.
Das ist die Klagemauer.
- Ah, okay, thank you.
Fragt sonst einfach um Hilfe,
das ist kein Problem hier, okay?
Thank you very much.
- Schönen Tag.
Thank you.- Bye.
- Bye.
Das ging jetzt schnell bis hier.
- Ja.
Beten die hier wohl oder reden sie?
Hör zu.
* Sprechgesang *
Bei uns ist es an religiösen Orten
doch immer so ruhig.
Ich weiss eben nicht, ob man die
Leute hier stören darf oder nicht.
Wenn die hier am Beten sind.
Der spricht zwar ...
Sorry, darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Ist dieser Teil hier nur für Männer?
- Ja.
Sind Sie aus Jerusalem?
Ich lebe in Israel, aber
ursprünglich komme ich aus Paris.
Sprecht ihr Französisch?
- Ja.
Wunderbar.
- Oui.
Jeden Montag und Donnerstag
nehmen wir die Thora heraus,
wie alle Juden.
Und so hat es heute
auch viele Bar-Mizwas.
* Fröhlicher Gesang *
* Geistlicher Gesang *
Bar-Mizwa ist wie die Erstkommunion
bei den Katholiken.
Mit 13 Jahren
wird hier der Junge zum Mann.
Vorher trägt der Vater die Verant-
wortung für die Taten seines Sohnes.
Ab 13 Jahren trägt der Sohn
selbst die Verantwortung.
Ah, voilà.
Alles, alles Gute.
- Bonne journée, merci.
Bonne journée à vous.
- Merci. Tout de bon.
Bonjour à la Suisse.
- Oui, on dit, on dit.
* Geistlicher Gesang *
Die Mauer ist sehr glatt.
Uneben.
- Ja, sehr.
Ou,
jetzt ist ein Zettel rausgefallen.
Oh, nein.
Willst du auch einen reinstecken?
- Hast du einen Zettel?
Ja. Warte kurz.
Wir haben gehört,
dass ganz viele Leute
Zettel in die Mauerritzen stecken.
Im Vorfeld fragte ich mich schon,
wie diese Ritzen wohl sind.
Ich konnte mir das
nicht so recht vorstellen.
Deshalb haben wir ein Papier
und einen Stift mitgenommen
und haben vor Ort auch einen Zettel
mit unseren Wünschen geschrieben.
Wie viele Wünsche
darf man wohl aufschreiben?
So viele wie du hast.
Hast du so viele Wünsche?
Aber ist das nicht ... Soll man sich
nicht mit einem zufriedengeben?
Das gibt ein Kunstwerk.
Gut ist,
dass es niemand lesen können muss.
Doch, Gott,
aber der versteht das schon.
Es hat fast keinen Platz mehr
für Wünsche.- Ja.
Die, die runterfallen,
werden scheinbar im Frühling
und im Herbst aufgesammelt.
Dann kommen sie auf den Ölberg,
auf den jüdischen Friedhof.
Die Wünsche gingen sicher
via Mauer in den Himmel.
Daran glaube ich schon sehr stark.
Da geschieht schon etwas.
Ich glaube schon daran,
dass es eine Art höhere Macht gibt.
Darum hoffe ich natürlich,
dass die Wünsche in Erfüllung gehen.
* Klingelton *
Oh, jetzt hat er wohl eines.
Yakir kommt uns abholen.
* Unverständliche Sprachausgabe *
Er ist noch 400 m von uns entfernt.
Dann ist er schon bald hier.
Viele Handys
haben eine Sprachausgabe,
die einem alles vorliest,
was auf dem Bildschirm steht.
Dadurch, können wir
ein "normales" Handy bedienen.
Wir haben die Sprachausgabe
immer schneller eingestellt.
Wir verstehen sie so,
weil wir die Sprachausgaben
schon extrem lang nutzen.
Noch 1 Min., noch 0,1 km,
also noch 100 m.
Hello? Ah, nein.
* Hupen *
Es hat gehupt, dann kommt er wohl.
Ah, hier. Are you a taxi?
Oder jener dort drüben?
- Ah, jetzt ruft er an.
Komm, Yves.
Hallo? Sehen Sie uns? Wir sind eben
blind, wir sehen Sie nicht.
Könnten Sie vielleicht hupen?
Bye, bye, okay. Bye, bye.
- Was macht er?
Sorry. Bye. Er ist weg.
- Er geht wieder?
Ja.
- So ein Arsch.
Also, ich bestelle ein anderes.
Ah, jetzt ist er hier.
* Hupen *
Ah, hier.
Hello?
Lass uns nachfragen.
Klopf mal ans Auto!
Sind Sie ein Taxi?- Nein,
aber 10 m weiter vorne wartet eins.
Ah, weiter vorne?
- Ja.Okay.
Sind Sie ein Taxi?
- Ja.
Sorry, wir haben Sie nicht gesehen.
- Kein Problem, ich habe gewartet.
Very nice.
- Thank you very much.
* Fröhliche israelische Musik *
Sind wir jetzt schon auf dem Ölberg?
- Ja.
Thank you.
- Thank you. Bye.
You're welcome.
- Bye.
Schön.
- Super.
Hier sind wir jetzt.
- Ja.
Hui, das windet extrem.
Huiuiui.
Woher kommt wohl dieser Wind?
Krass. Es windet extrem.
Hello? Sorry.
- Braucht ihr Hilfe?
Ja. Könnten Sie uns vielleicht etwas
beschreiben, was man hier so sieht?
Oh, sehr viel.
* Yves lacht. *
Es ist sozusagen die gesamte Sicht
auf die Altstadt von Jerusalem.
Im Zentrum ist der Felsendom.
- Ah, okay.
Er ist blau
und seine Kuppel ist aus Gold.
Ah, okay.
Wir sind auf der Seite
des jüdischen Friedhofes.
Auf der anderen Seite des Tales,
unterhalb der Stadtmauer,
befindet sich
der muslimische Friedhof.
Ah, okay.
- Ja.
Also, weiterhin gute Reise.
Merci.
Und danke für die Beschreibung.
Merci beaucoup,
c'était cool de te rencontrer.
Merci beaucoup.
- Amusez-vous!
Toi aussi! Bonne soirée. Merci.
Tchao, tchao.
Es gibt doch so einen Panoramamodus.
Da fährt man so hin und her und
dann gibt es ein schönes Panorama -
wenn man es kann.
- Aha.
Und jetzt fühlst du dich überlegen,
weil du diesen Panoramamodus hast?
Nein, es bringt mir ja nichts, denn
ich habe ja kein Instagram wie du.
Ja, ja, du kannst schon lachen.
Kann ich dir helfen?
* Drollige Streichermusik *
Ja, ja. Wir können ja
noch ein Selfie machen.
Das können wir ja besser.
Du schaust schief.
- Ah.
Jetzt. Zwei Gesichter.
- Ja. Jetzt musst du aber ...
Uh, ja.
- Warte schnell.
Jetzt. Drück.
Nochmals.
- Nochmals?- Ja.
Spürst du jetzt Jesus hier?
Wieso? War er hier?
Ja, von hier aus
ist er doch in den Himmel.- Ja?
* Schnelle orientalische Musik *
* Die Musik endet abrupt. *
* Stimmengewirr, Rufe *
Zweimal Hummus, bitte.
Jetzt geht es gleich los.
Oh, Fladenbrot.
Hier ist der Hummus.
Das Pitabrot.
- Ja.
Und hier Falafel.
Oh!
Wow, thank you.
Thank you.
Es hat Falafel.
- Hat jeder einen eigenen Teller?
Du hast hier Falafel.
- Ja.
Ich verstehe es nicht ganz.
Wo ist denn der Hummus?
Ah, hier. Nein, das ist Salat.
Das hier ist Hummus.
Auf dem Teller?
- Ja.
Brot hast du schon, oder?
Die Falafel sind hier vorne.
Das ist sehr lecker.
- Sehr lecker, ja.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Mmh.
Shukran.
Und jetzt weiss ich nicht,
ob hier ...
* Helles Klimpern *
Oh, hier ist eine Bank.
Wollen wir uns hier hinsetzen?
Ja, hier ist eine Bank.
- Ja.
Hm, es riecht etwas streng.
- Wirklich?
Wonach?
- Nach Kacke.
Wirklich?
- Dann sitzt auf Kacke.
Wirklich? Ich rieche es nicht.
Wir gingen in Jerusalem
zum Fussballklub Katamon,
weil wir im Vorfeld gehört hatten,
dass dort Menschen verschiedener
Religionen zusammen Fussball spielen
und so näher zusammenrücken.
Wir haben im Internet recherchiert
und schnell die Website gefunden.
Und so kamen wir zu Uri Sheratzky.
Hello, I'm Uri.
- Hello, nice to meet you. I'm Yves.
Yves and?
- Jonas. Nice to meet you.
Jonas, nice to meet you.
Ich habe euch
ein kleines Geschenk mitgebracht.
Eine Mütze von unserem Club,
Schutz vor der israelischen Sonne.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
So you can put it
on your head afterwards.
Also, ich erzähle euch mal etwas
über den Katamon-Klub, okay?
Jerusalem tut nur so,
als ob es  e i n e  Stadt wäre.
Aber das täuscht -
es sind drei Städte.
Eine für Menschen wie mich:
nicht-orthodoxe.
Eine weitere Stadt
ist die der muslimischen
und der christlichen Araber.
Und die dritte Stadt
ist die der orthodoxen Juden.
Jeder Teil hat eigene Schulen.
Einige haben sogar ihren eigenen ÖV.
Alle haben eigene Nachbarn,
eine eigene Kultur
und eine eigene Sprache.
Es sind also drei Städte.
Also heisst das, dass jeder Teil
seinen eigenen Fussballklub hat?
Nein, da kommen wir ins Spiel.
Wir versuchen, ein Ort zu sein,
an dem sich die drei Kulturen
der Stadt treffen können.
Es ist sehr kompliziert.
Aber wir haben Fussballfelder
in der ganzen Stadt
und Schulen,
mit denen wir arbeiten.
Von den israelischen Siedlungen
bis zu den arabischen Stadtteilen
ganz im Osten.
Darf ich mich festhalten?
- Yes, sure.
Was habt ihr denn
schon alles gesehen?
Sehen ist vielleicht
nicht das richtige Wort.
Nein, nein, das ist schon gut.
What did you feel in Jerusalem?
- We saw the Western Wall.
* Ein Mann
gibt Anweisungen auf Hebräisch. *
Ist hier das Fussballfeld?
- Ja.
In front of you is a football field.
- Ah, yes.
Now you can touch it.
- Ja.
Oh, ja.- Da hat es Sand ...
There's sand in it.
Spürt ihr,
wie heiss der Kunstrasen ist?
Es ist schwierig, darauf zu spielen.
This is Digati.
Nice to meet you.
- My name ist Digati.
Sie sind der Trainer?
Ja, vom Jugendsektor.
Dann hat es hier also
Palästinenser, Muslime und Christen?
Palästinenser ... nun ja.
Aber es hat Araber, Äthiopier.
Jede Kultur ist vertreten.
(Yves und Jonas) Okay.
Palästinenser
könnten bei uns beitreten.
Aber wenn die Palästinenser
einem jüdischen Club
wie unserem beitreten,
bekommen sie Probleme mit
ihren Leuten in ihren Stadtteilen.
Deshalb nehmen sie nur an den inof-
fiziellen Aktivitäten von uns teil.
Man darf auch nicht
in der israelischen Liga spielen,
wenn man keine Israel-ID hat.
Wollt ihr mit einem arabischen Vater
sprechen?- Yes.
Abuhalled!
Hi, I'm Jonas. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Hello. Welche Sprache sprichst du?
- Englisch.
Ah, nice.
- Und was sonst? Just English?
Arabisch, Hebräisch und Französisch.
- Ah, okay.
Und ich bin neun Jahre alt.
- Wow.
Und wer ist der beste Fussballer?
Ronaldo und Messi.
- Ah.
Spielen Sie auch Fussball?
Ich habe mal gespielt, aber jetzt
bin ich 46 und ich bin Anwalt.
Der Alltag ist schwierig hier
mit all den Problemen.
Was meinen Sie mit Problemen?
Wir können nicht ignorieren,
dass die Situation hier
nicht einfach ist.
Es gibt viele Konflikte.
Aber wenn die Menschen
in sich drin einen Spirit finden,
um zusammenzuleben,
dann können sie zusammenleben.
Wenn wir die Politik beiseitelassen,
dann können die Menschen
es gut haben miteinander.
Und das schönste Beispiel dafür
ist dieser Fussballklub.
* Orientalische Klänge *
(Mann) ... il Signore è con te.
Tu sei benedetta ...
Spannend finde ich,
dass man an den Kleidern sieht,
wenn jemand sehr religiös ist.
Das sehen die Sehenden ja sofort,
auf den ersten Blick.
Vielleicht sehen sie
auch sonst den Kleidern an,
ob jemand Jude oder Muslim ist -
oder sogar,
ob jemand Polizist ist oder nicht.
Das sehen wir nicht.
Das finde ich eigentlich noch schön.
Ich finde, das ist
einer unserer grossen Vorteile,
dass wir nicht urteilen, bevor wir
mit jemandem gesprochen haben.
... e si è caricato
dei nostri dolori.
The Third Station.
When Jesus falls the first time.
Ich liebe Wasser über alles
und mag Baden sehr.
Ich bin allgemein gerne am Meer.
Man hört von Leuten,
die bereits am Toten Meer waren,
dass es ein einmaliges Erlebnis
sein soll.
Das Gefühl, auf dem Wasser ...
liegen zu können.
Das Gefühl hat mich gereizt.
* Die Tür quietscht. *
Can I go inside?
Thank you.
Wie lange dauert die Fahrt
bis ans Tote Meer?
Eigentlich 40 Min.,
aber manchmal hat es Stau.
Und von dort ist es nicht mehr weit
bis nach Jordanien, oder?
Nein, man kann die Häuser sehen
auf der jordanischen Seite
des Toten Meeres.- Okay.
Könnten Sie uns etwas beschreiben,
was man unterwegs so sieht?
Wir fahren nun Richtung Jericho.
Das ist eine Strasse für alle.
Die Palästinenser können sie
benutzen, aber auch die Israeli,
weil sie in die Westbank geht, aber
auch zu jüdischen Siedlungen führt.
Rechts könnt ihr die Mauer sehen
zwischen Israel und Palästina.
Das ist also die Grenze zwischen ...
... between the Palestinian
and the Israelian side.
Ah, okay.
Und müssen wir nicht
durch einen Checkpoint?
Nein,
weil wir in diese Richtung fahren.
Ah, okay, it's only to ...
Schaut mal, auf der anderen Seite
hat es sehr viele Autos.
Haben die Palästinenser
einen anderen Pass?
Sie haben
einen palästinensischen Pass.
Ich gehöre zu den Arabern,
die in Jerusalem leben.
Wir haben entweder einen jorda-
nischen Pass und eine Israel-ID
oder einige haben
die israelische Staatsbürgerschaft.
Wie ist es denn für Sie,
in Jerusalem zu leben?
Es ist sehr schön und speziell.
Ein Segen.
Ich bin hier geboren,
und unser Haus gehört meiner Familie
seit der jordanischen Zeit.
Wir werden
unsere Häuser nicht verlassen.
Aber ist es manchmal
nicht auch schwierig?
Sehr schwierig. Sehr.
Aber was können wir machen?
Wir müssen geduldig sein.
Ich habe viele israelische Freunde,
weil ich
in einem Hotel gearbeitet habe.
Es gibt auf beiden Seiten
gute Menschen und schlechte.
Auf beiden Seiten.
Vielleicht sind ja
gar nicht die Menschen das Problem.
Nein,
nur die Politik ist das Problem.
Der Politik sind die Menschen egal.
Sie kümmert sich um anderes.
Es geht ums Geschäft.
* Arabische Klänge *
Ich habe es sehr interessant
gefunden, was Mahmud gesagt hat
und wie er dieses Leben akzeptiert.
Vielleicht hat er sich aber auch
einfach eine gute Art zurechtgelegt,
wie er das erzählen möchte.
Ich bin noch unentschlossen.
Es ist einfach eine ganz andere Welt
und ich finde es schwierig,
sie zu verstehen.
* Orientalische Klänge *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Das ist ja heiss
wie in einem Backofen.
It's hotter than in Jerusalem.
Es ist 10 °C heisser
als in Jerusalem.
Warum denn das? Nur weil es
auf einer anderen Höhe liegt?
Ja, wir sind hier
400 m unter dem Meeresspiegel.
Hier vorne
reiten Kinder auf einem Kamel.
Wow, es gibt hier Kamele.
So gut.
Come here.
Here is a chair.
- Ah, thank you.
Es sind einfach Stühle.
Wollen wir gleich ins Wasser?
- Ich glaube schon.
It is not far to the water
from here.
Können Sie uns zeigen,
wo das Wasser ist?
Thank you.
Können wir dann einfach
immer weiter ins Meer hineingehen
oder dürfen wir
nur ein paar Schritte machen?
Ihr könnt schon etwas reinlaufen.
Da vorne ist das Wasser.
This is my friend.
Hello.
Er ist ein Freund von mir,
er wird euch helfen.
Thank you.
- Die Schuhe könnt ihr hier lassen.
Okay, come.
Wie ist es?
- Es ist herrlich.
Grossartig.
Ihr werdet nachher jünger aussehen.
Geniesst es.
Ich bin hier, wenn ihr raus wollt.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
* Ruhige, entspannte Musik *
Yves?
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Ja, ich bin hier.
Krass.
Es ist ein Supergefühl,
da drin zu liegen
und es einfach geniessen zu können.
Man schwebt eigentlich
über dem Wasser.
Ich glaube, dieses Gefühl
werde ich nie mehr vergessen.
Es ist unglaublich.
Yves?
- Ja?
Liegst du?
- Ja, und du?
Ja.
* Entspannte Akkordeonmusik *
Ja, gleich müssen wir ...
Das ist wohl ...
Guten Tag.
- Wo wollt ihr hin?
Geradeaus an die Quai du Mont-Blanc.
Quai du Mont-Blanc?
- Oui. Tout droit?
Nein, da müsst ihr links.
- Nach links?
À gauche, c'est près à ...
- Also hier?
Ja, hier.
- Ah, okay.
Merci beaucoup.
Dann wohl etwas zurück, oder?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob wir hier rüber können.
Pas là, pas là, ici.
- Ah, ici?
On est en travaux, oui.
- Ah, ici, Yves.
Ici.
Hier kommt eine Baustelle. Ich weiss
nicht, ob du das gehört hast.
Mit dem Probedreh in Genf
hat alles begonnen.
Da haben wir herausgefunden,
dass Genf an einem See liegt.
Vous voulez changer
pour aller d'eau?
(Beide) Oui.
- Venez avec moi.- Merci.
Das war die erste Challenge,
ob das wohl gut ausgeht.
Werden uns die Leute uns helfen?
Können wir ihnen spontan begegnen?
Laufen sie nicht davon,
auch wenn sie eine Kamera sehen?
All das mussten wir
erst einmal ausprobieren.
Wir haben uns
immer etwas gesteigert.
Das erste Mal
waren wir in Genf im See,
dann im Meer und dann im Toten Meer.
Ich erinnere mich noch,
dass wir in Genf ein
grandioses Entrecôte gegessen haben.
Im Restaurant, in dem
Café de Paris erfunden wurde.
(Lachend) Ja.
So lernt man die Kultur
sehr gut kennen.
Das Essen
sagt sehr viel darüber aus.
Essen ist für uns beide
etwas ziemlich Wichtiges.
Manchmal hatten wir typisches Essen,
manchmal weniger typisches.
In Athen
haben wir Hamburger gegessen.
Ah, da ist ein Pfosten.
Um mich herum.
- Da, hier ist ein Pfosten.
Ja, ja.
* Lachen *
Hier ist eine Kurve.
- Warte kurz.
* Klackern des Blindenstocks *
Voilà. C'est toi qui ...
Wenn ich an "Blindflug" zurückdenke,
ist es für mich ein grosses,
wunderbar schönes Projekt,
wie ein schönes Fotoalbum
oder eine schöne Erinnerung
an eine wunderbare Zeit.
* Gemächliche Musik *
* Die Musik läuft weiter
in den Kopfhörern. *
Mit blindem Vertrauen.
- Das kann man so sagen.
Blauäugig.
- Ja.
Wir müssen fast noch eines machen.
Auf "Selfie" ... Ah, drauf klicken.
- Ich lasse dich etwas üben.
"Ein Gesicht am rechten ..."
- Unten.
Jetzt drücken. Ja. Oh je.
- Oh. Nach links neigen.
Ob das wohl schön ist?
Schön sicher nicht.
- Mach du das.
Ja, jetzt!
- Jetzt muss du lachen.
Ja, ich lache.
* Klicken *
Hast du gedrückt?
- Ja.
War das wieder eine Zangengeburt.
Falls wir noch einmal eine Reise
machen und etwas Budget haben,
besorgen wir einen Selfiestick.
Den kannst du gerne
auf dein Budget nehmen.
* Yves lacht. *
Oh, wo geht es hier durch?
- Ah, hier. Nein.
Doch, es geht schon.
Die Sträucher wachsen etwas raus.
Du kannst hier rund herum.
- Nein, hier kommt man nicht durch.
Nicht? Nein, hier.
- Oder hier.
Hier, hier.
- Ja.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Maria Krähenbühl - 2020